presidents who have
folks who have congratulated biden and
who hasn't congratulated biden who has
congratulated biden
maduro from venezuela
yeah to the brotherhood go type in what
maduro said about biden type in
what maduro said about biden it's it's
very good when maduro
is uh congratulating you but biden let's
type that and see uh
uh two days ago he said if you go to his
instagram account anyways
there's nobody more happy than him that
piden won of course but there's a couple
other people that are also happy as much
as he is
uh here's the folks that haven't
congratulated him
uh let me see what i have here president
obama congratulate him kai where is the
sheep putin hasn't yet has not
congratulations has not
hasn't brazil president has not yet yes
she hasn't yet
yet erdogan has india mexican president
hasn't yet
and uh a lot of other people have can i
get can i give you my wild
crazy theory why i mean this is really
out there so stay with me on this one
the reason i think some of these world
leaders haven't congratulated biden yet
is because
he hasn't won yet okay he hasn't
officially won the election
good one tom uh let's talk about um the
the people who have congratulations yeah
uh
french president emmanuel macron boris
johnson hardcore socialism from uk
exactly uh merkel netanyahu from israel
um justin trudeau of canada has
congratulated him
uh george w bush remember him i'm not
sure he's congratulated
mitt romney we all know that those guys
were world leaders
modi from india and uh
south korea modi netanyahu very
impressive
for them to have congratulations who has
not congratulated him
vladimir putin democrat uh dictator she
authoritarian erdogan dictator and
authoritarian
bolsonaro trump of the tropics um i'm
just waiting on kim jong-un
see where he's at with this so can you
go i got five minutes i know i got five
minutes can you go on what comment he
said about
uh the election process in the u.s it
was very interesting this is khamenei
uh saying uh the situation in the us and
what they themselves say about their
election spec
is a spectacle this is an example of the
ugly face of liberal democracy in the
u.s regardless of the outcome one thing
is absolutely
clear the definite political civil and
moral decline
of the us regime coming from iran
yeah hard to argue with that but at
least we're able to freaking vote
okay at least we're able to vote whether
you vote for trump or you vote for biden
at least you're able to frickin
vote he sounds like a trump not in iran
though guy yeah it's interesting to see
what he's saying
[Music]